oui
[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans cette
grande interview enregistrée dans des
conditions un peu particulières puisque
nous sommes au forum économique de saint
pétersbourg avec comme invité christian
cambon bonjour bonjour président de la
commission des affaires étrangères et de
la défense au sénat
c'est la première fois monsieur le
président que vous êtes invités au forum
alors que vous êtes un spécialiste de la
russie un ami quelque part de la russie
bon connaisseur des relations
franco-russes votre première impression
en impression et elle est évidemment
tout à fait admiratif sur l'organisation
de cette manifestation que je ne
connaissais pas que j'avais été invité à
plusieurs reprises je n'avais pas eu la
possibilité de venir et je vois
l'importance de cette organisation la
présence des entreprises notamment
français et moi à la demande du
président du sénat j'ai souhaité venir
ici d'abord bien sûr pour soutenir nos
entreprises françaises les
les grandes entreprises qui ce matin
sont intervenus et ont développé
largement la coopération le partenariat
qui se développe avec de nombreuses
entreprises russes et puis bien sûr il
ya aussi une signification politique de
la part du sénat que je représente ici
dans un moment où les relations entre
l'europe et la russie ne sont pas au
beau fixe
et donc c'est important de venir
dialoguer et de se parler alors on va en
parler de cet aspect politique mais
l'objet du forum de saint-pétersbourg
c'est quand même de renforcer la
coopération économique et de trouver des
conditions de développement harmonieuse
quelle est la représentation française
est ce qu'elle est important oui elle
est très importante et j'ai entendu un
chiffre que je sous-estimaient notion
que je sous-estimait la france est le
premier employeur étranger en russie
ah oui premier employeur par le nombre
d'entreprises et le nombre d'emplois qui
est que ces entreprises créées c'est
tout à fait formidable et je pense que
c'est assez méconnu c'est quelque chose
qu'on ne s'est pas très bien
par ailleurs on voit bien que ces
entreprises se développent dans tous les
secteurs
que ce soit bien sûr celui de l'énergie
l énergie avec total
schneider electric on a aussi auchan qui
était un pourvoyeur d'emplois et de
richesses très important et qui apporte
ici un petit peu du savoir faire en
matière de consommation et de
distribution alimentaire que qui se
développe en france mais on le voit
aussi dans tout un tas d'autres
entreprises et notamment toutes celles
qui sont en train de près de préparer le
changement climatique
et ça j'ai trouvé que les échanges de ce
matin était vraiment très intéressant
car entre la russie et la france
il y a des vrais coopération dans le
domaine des batteries de la production
d'hydrogène dans la gestion future de
l'arctique
je trouve que tout ça c'est des sujets
méconnu et qui méritent qu'on les
soutienne
sauf quand on est à fond s'affrontent à
une concurrence à l'intérieur même de
l'europe sur le marché russe puisque les
allemands sont traditionnellement mieux
positionné que nous oui d'une certaine
façon mais moi j'ai pu tout trouvé pas
mal d'espérance dans ce que j'ai entendu
ce matin parce que le savoir-faire
l'innovation les partenariats sont
vraiment très dynamique
bien sûr les allemands sont présents ils
l'ont toujours été mais je crois que au
contraire c'est le moment de dire bien
sûr aux grandes entreprises qui nous la
présente
mais aussi à nos petites et moyennes
entreprises il faut venir en russie
travailler car il ya des secteurs de
développement dans tous les domaines qui
sont vraiment très prometteur
c'est peut-être aux grandes entreprises
d'emmener dans leurs bagages voilà les
petites voilà il ya une sorte qu il ya
une sorte de parrainage qui peut être
effectuée car en plus avec eux des
compagnies bancaires en matière
d'assurance aussi que j'ai rencontré ce
matin et qui montre que là aussi à un
environnement très favorable pour
l'entreprise française quand elle vient
ici alors est-ce que c'est facile de
travailler en russie
est-ce que c'est facile d'aborder ce
marché dans la mesure où son image
vous le disiez et pas excellemment
considéré par l'opinion publique
européenne et dans la mesure aussi où il
ya la barrière de la langue
ouais je pense que c'est à la fois
facile et compliqué facile au sens où
nous avons quand même une culture assez
commune des partages
de civilisation qui sont quand même très
commun et je crois que ce que
pelé gruss attendre c'est que l'on
apporte de l'innovation c'est qu'on
apporte un plus on n'est pas dans la
situation où les marchés sont signé tout
de suite
il faut apporter quelque chose et dès
qu'une entreprise apporte un plus dans
la gestion
j'entendais de leurs lecteurs de
schneider electric qui a réussi à
connecter tout un tas d'entreprises
russes qui leur permettent maintenant
d'être au niveau de l'intelligence
artificielle ce qui se fait de mieux
là là évidemment les russes disent on a
besoin de vous on vous tend la main
alors il ya des possibilités il ya des
potentialités vous venez de décret il ya
cependant un climat qui est un peu
pollué par des considérations politiques
des allinges politiques qui n'ont pas
forcément beaucoup gêner le
développement jusqu'à maintenant il ya
eu des sanctions il ya encore la russie
vit encore souveraine un certain nombre
de sanctions
et elles sont menacées la russie est
menacé de nouvelles sanctions
alors qu'est-ce que comment vous aborder
cette question
c'est évidemment ce qui peut lui un
petit peu
et
la situation et le débat d'une mère
général par c'est ce que souhaite de
rester chef d'entreprise que j'entendais
ce matin c'est surtout que leurs
affaires ne viennent pas être pollué par
ses relations politiques qui sont ce
qu'elles sont et sur lesquels les
milieux économiques nous n'ont pas
beaucoup de prise
mais il ne faudrait pas que les
difficultés politiques qui peuvent
exister entre le gouvernement russe et
puis l'europe d'où un général notre pays
particulièrement viennent empêcher ce
développement économique dont on nous a
dont on a absolument besoin
alors évidemment le responsable
politique que je suis est à la fois
solidaire quelque part des décisions
gouvernementales qui sont prises mais
avec la volonté de faire vibrer notre
petite musique au sénat il consiste à
dire le dialogue est un élément
permanent est un élément essentiel pour
qu'un jour on arrête les sanctions
il ya des progrès qui doit qui sont
attendus évidemment il ya des signaux
que nous attendons et je pense que nos
collègues russes en attendent aussi de
notre part je vais du reste avoir des
entretiens de haut niveau avec les
responsables politiques qui sont
présents ici
je pense notamment que les sanctions
personnelles qui visent des
parlementaires c'est quelque chose de
très négatif car nous devrons absolument
conserver cette capacité de dialoguer
entre nous si on ne s'explique pas
comment surmonter les difficultés
alors au delà de ces sanctions
personnelles il ya la menace d'une
sanction plus générale de prononcer
l'exclusion de la russie du système de
financement international ce qui aurait
des effets est gravissime pour
l'économie russe on a bien vu ce que ça
a donné
en iran est-ce qu'on n'est pas là d'où
européen
le jouet des américains quelque part je
pense que du maire générale l'europe
doit savoir parler sur ces sujets de
manière autonome
nous n'avons dieu sait si les américains
nous met une pression alors même qu'ils
ciblent je vois aujourd'hui combien ils
sont présents de nombreux alors qu'ils
ont l'air de nous interdire d'être deux
développer le dialogue avec les russes
et je les vois le ici très présent et de
quelle manière marquée tout le monde
voilà alors je pense que c'est un
argument supplémentaire pour dire que
l'europe elle doit retrouver son
autonomie compris sur le plan politique
et dans sa relation et et nous avons
tout à fait les capacités pour le faire
la france le fait elle sait mettre en
oeuvre des moyens politiques qui
permettent un dialogue franco russe n'a
vu le président poutine à plusieurs
reprises via paris échangé avec le
président de macron et puis quand la
france considère que certains événements
peuvent
nous choquer on le dit c'est pas
totalement clair et pas cohérents c'est
jamais gaubert au niveau européen c'est
pas forcément cohérence ps parce qu'au
niveau européen il ya des intérêts
contradictoires
il ya des pays qui favorise le business
quoi qu'ils disent écoutez les c et puis
y en a d'autres qui tiennent des
discours est ce qu'on n'est pas et selon
aviva pardonnez-moi partager aussi entre
notre fidélité à la vérité à son
parapluie
au niveau de la défense nationale notre
appartenance à l'otan et puis la
proximité géographique et la complice et
la cohabitation avec les intérêts
économiques russes
on est partagé par ça c'est pas où on
est on s'assoit exactement est-ce que
c'est assez compliqué parce qu'il ya un
certain nombre de principes sur lequel
auquel on ne peut pas déroger
nous appartenons à l'otan je suis à la
délégation parlementaire le temps oui
bon mais j'observe du reste très souvent
la délégation française tente d'atténuer
les discours excessivement belliciste
que l'on entend parfois ici ou là et
pour remettre les choses à niveau quand
on entend le temps que le seul
adversaire c'est la russie je pense que
le terrorisme que nous subissons depuis
le sud
les beaucoup plus ceci dit vous disiez
les affaires économiques ne doivent pas
être pollué par les affaires politiques
mais l'homme politique vous êtes est
bien obligé de les prendre en
considération quand il est confronté à
ses électeurs au sénat quelle est la
position du sénat là dessus la position
du sénat c'est de dialoguer toujours
avec persévérance c'est ce que nous
avons fait c'est tout à fait original
l'assemblée nationale ne l'a pas fait
nous avons réalisé nous avons commis
deux rapports ensemble pour bien
identifier à la fois les les points
d'accord ils sont très nombreux dans le
domaine de l'espace de la lutte contre
le terrorisme de l'environnement de la
culture de l'université etc
et puis ce que les nos collègues russes
apprécient c'est la clarté des positions
lorsque nous ne sommes pas d'accord
c'est vrai que la france n'est pas
d'accord sur la manière dont la russie a
procédé en crimée on veut dire les
choses telles qu'elles sont sur
l'ukraine
nous avons des conversations très
approfondie nous voulons éclairer aussi
un petit peu le rôle que
car la russie en afrique qui posent
actuellement un certain nombre de
questions mais je ce qui est très
intéressant avec nos collègues russes
c'est qu'il n'y a jamais de refus de la
discussion
alors c'est évidemment par avec le
dialogue que l'on pourra avancer c'est
pas brusquement les choses vont pas
changer d'un jour où d'un nous ce qu'on
a tendance parfois à reprocher à la
russie à l'exécutif russe
c'est de ne pas semer la zizanie dans
les pays européens mais c'est d'éviter
que les pays en baisse ou à trop
d'accord entre eux vous avez auriez vous
êtes d'accord oui je sais je souris
parce que puisque je je pilote un petit
peu les relations internationales sous
l'autorité du président du sénat au
sénat c'est ce que je vois de toutes les
grandes puissances les chinois lorsqu'il
nous parle il adore ne parlait qu'à la
france et ne pas parler aux autres les
américains tout autant donc ça c'est pas
tout à fait c'est pas tout à fait
nouveau on l'acceptent mais bien
évidemment il ya un certain de
solidarité au sein de l'europe
mais c'est aussi à nous et je crois que
la france a un rôle modérateur très
important il ya des propos qui sont
tenus dans certains ont d'autres pays
sont très hostiles à la russie et je
pense que le rôle de la france manque du
conseil de sécurité et une relation tout
à fait privilégiée est qu'il ya eu dans
le passé des relations privilégiées avec
la russie
eh bien nous devons essayer de remettre
les choses en ligne et par exemple en
matière de coopération économique comme
nous le bois voyons ici c'est un élément
positif sur lequel on peut pas
que l'on ne peut pas passer sous silence
est ce que vous pensez pour terminer
qu'on pourrait s'y remettre en ligne
aussi en matière de coopération en sur
le domaine de la santé du médicament et
notamment du vaccin vous n'êtes pas sans
savoir que les russes ne comprennent pas
bien que leur vaccin qui est vendu dans
le monde entier
ce soir a reconnu par les autorités
européennes yala à la fois un effet
contre-productif
il ya aussi un effet politique
vraisemblablement comment est-ce qu'on
peut sortir de ce dernier il est
important pour les russes mais bien sûr
il ya eu un échange du reste entre le
président poutine il présent mâcon sur
ce sujet est présent poutine a demandé
un appui de la france une mission trésor
alors qu'ils venaient ici
à partir de là moi je crois qu'il faut
il faut surtout pas en faire une affaire
politique d'hier c'est un vaccin réseau
d'un vaccin mauvais je pense que tout ça
n'a pas de sens il faut laisser les
autorités sanitaires qui sont quand même
seul responsable de notre santé publique
en général nous dira si ce vaccin est
bon et s'il l'est eh bien mon dieu
pourquoi pas le vaccin reste soit je
veux dire moi je ne suis pas en mesure
car je n'ai aucune compétence dans ce
domaine de la santé
je ne suis pas en mesure de dire si
c'est un bon vaccin d'un pas bon vaccin
en revanche si c'est un bon vaccin il
faut véritablement que
mais pour la russie c'est un outil
d'exportation très important c'est un
outil de valeur ajoutée et mais c'est
aussi un outil politique
oui puisqu'ils sont en train de vacciner
une partie du bon et tout dans laquelle
nous sommes absorbés
disons que c'est plutôt une bonne chose
parce que quand on voit les ouailles
artistique de vaccination en afrique par
exemple
franchement c'est pas ni la france ni
l'europe qui vont régler le problème à
elle seule donc s'il ya des bonnes
volontés et la russie eut peut en faire
partie ils sont les bienvenus
christian cambon merci beaucoup merci je
rappelle que vous êtes président au
sénat de la commission de la défense
nationale et des affaires étrangères
merci bon forum merci à nous étions dans
la grande interview pour r d vous l'a
retrouvé en replay vous l'a retrouvée
sur les réseaux sociaux mais vous la
retrouver évidemment sur le site
internet
rt france 3 tv
[Musique]